hello my name is Ruslan nazarov I'm a
professor at Yale University School of
Medicine and an investigator of the
Howard Hughes Medical Institute and I
will discuss today our work on
characterizing toll-like receptors and
their role in control of adaptive
immunity my story started in this
building this is a library for Natural
Sciences of russian academy of sciences
in moscow when i was a graduate student
there from 1992-93 at that time soviet
union just collapsed and there was a
profound economic crisis so there was no
Regents to to be able to experimental
work and there were not even periodicals
to be able to read and this was the only
library that still had a subscription to
nature science cell and other journals
and so I would go there every morning
and spend all day in this library on the
second floor and just trying to read the
literature since I I wasn't really able
to do much in the lab at the time and
during one of this trips to the library
I completely randomly run into a paper
written by the late Charles Janeway that
changed the direction of my career and
life and this was a paper in that
appeared in the Proceedings of the Cold
Spring Harbor Laboratory from 1989 and
this is the paper it was entitled
approaching the asymptote evolution and
evolution in immunology and this is
Charlie Janeway who unfortunately passed
away in 2003 but what he described in
that paper was a new perspective and new
theory to think about the immune system
that when I read it I thought that this
is makes so much sense and this is going
to completely revolutionize
our understanding of immunity and I got
completely enchanted with this idea and
this logical framework that charlie
proposed there and that was the time
when I became interested in immunology
and to put this into historical context
what the idea was about is how the
immune system knows when to be activated
and when to respond to a challenge and
what was thought at the time is that the
immune system t-cells and b-cells only
reacted to foreign antigens but not to
self antigens for example antigens that
come from our own tissues and so on the
top panel you will see here a situation
where self antigens that may be
presented by antigen presenting cells so
a PCS to t-cells but there would be no
response
even though t-cells can see the antigen
they should not be responding and at the
lower part you see the situation where
there is an infection and when APC is
detect pathogens then there should be
response as we all know we respond to
pathogens but it wasn't clear what makes
the difference and again one idea was
that the immune system distinguished
between self antigens and non-self
antigens so pathogens will be non-self
immune system will react self antigens
ourself and the immune system would not
react but and there was also known at
the time that for T cells to become
activated they require two signals and
one signal is the antigen itself which
is presented by MHC molecules major
histocompatibility complex molecules so
it's a complex between MHC an antigen
that is seen by T cells and what became
known at the time from the work of
Ron Schwarz and Mark Jenkins at the NIH
that when t-cells see only signal one
there is no response that is generated
but when they see two signals the second
signal also coming from antigen
presenting cells that then there would
be a response and the identity of that
second signal was subsequently
characterized and it's known as
molecules called b7 one b7 two or cd8
ECT eighty-six
so that was the state of knowledge and
it was many different views about what
controls activation of the adaptive
immune response of T cells and B cells
and there are different sort of schools
of thought and and it was still very
much unclear for somebody who's coming
from the outside of the field what was
going on and how the system worked and
that's what was changed with this
article by Charlie Janeway where he
proposed that in fact what might be
happening is that in addition to t-cell
receptors and immunoglobulin receptors
there is a whole different set of
receptors that are shown here in blue
that Charlie hypothesized would be
involved in direct detection of
pathogens and that these receptors would
then control expression of the signal
tool and in this manner when antigen
presenting cells encounter self antigens
or any other antigens that are not
infectious there would be just signal
one and there will be no response but
when they encounter pathogens then there
would be this detection by these
hypothetical receptors of common
microbial structures and that would lead
to the induction of signal 2 and that
would result in the immune response and
that was a very profound insight and it
was a very beautiful idea that made so
much sense and and Charlie further
proposed that these receptors that he
called pattern recognition receptors
because they detect conserved patterns
found in a tagines things like liver
saccharides b-t-dub lichens and so forth
he proposed this receptors are
evolutionary ancient and they involved
in immunity in invertebrates as well as
in vertebrates where they control the
innate arm of the immune system but in
addition invertebrates they acquire a
second function where they control
activation of the adaptive immune system
and that was a really a revolutionary
proposition and the only problem was
that the receptors that Charlie
hypothesized should exist were not known
at the time and and so after reading
Charlie's paper I started communicating
with him initially through email and
eventually I was fortunate enough to be
able to join his lab as a as a postdoc
in 1994 and then my focus of my research
was on trying to identify such receptors
that can control expression of signal to
to induce to control activation of
adaptive immunity and at that time there
was really little known about how
microbes can be recognized directly
there were a few proteins that were
known to bind to microbial cell walls
one of them was a protein called mana
and binding lectin from the confidence
system another a cd14 molecule which is
a gpi-anchored protein on macrophages
and there are a few proteins known in
invertebrates that were involved in
recognition of LPS but other than that
there was really not clear what this
receptor is supposed to look like and
how they how to identify them and a
couple of things that changed that
played a role in the development of the
story was that one was in 1994 the year
when I joined Charlie lab David
Baltimore came to Yale to give a talk
and our department and at that time he
just his lab just started characterizing
the first knockouts for NF kappa-b which
is a critical transcription factor
involved in inflammation and there he
talked about the phenotype of thirst and
of can be knockouts
which had both defects and innate and an
adaptive immune response and I remember
after David's talk Charlie and I were
talking in the hallway and we both
thought that whatever it is that we're
looking for
it's whatever these receptors are they
probably work by activating in F Kappa B
and then we thought okay so one criteria
we should use is that they they are
likely to be enough Kappa B activators
and at that time the only two receptor
family is known to activate an F Kappa B
where T and F family and aisle one
receptor family and one receptor is the
one that we got particularly interested
in because of this remarkable
conservation in one receptor signaling
portion with a receptor that at the time
was already known to exist in Drosophila
and in Drosophila that receptor is
called Paul that receptor was identified
in corn in Kathryn Anderson's lab by Col
Hashimoto at the time they were at
Berkley and the signaling pathway was
elucidated by several investigators
including Steve was Herman & MacLean
Catherine Anderson and others and it was
known that this pathway operates in fly
development but what was interesting for
us is that it worked through NF kappa-b
in flies and the related receptor aisle
one receptor worked through enough Kappa
B in mammals and what they shared is the
cytoplasmic portion shown here in blue
whereas their actual domains involved in
liking recognition were unrelated and
because of this conservation we splice
and because one receptor is involved in
inflammation we thought that perhaps the
receptor that we are looking for would
be would have this C terminal signaling
domain and the actor domain perhaps
would be something that
and recognize microbes and the only
structures that are were known at the
time to recognize microbial components
were Sita lectins so I thought that
maybe there is another version of this
receptor that has cytoplasmic signaling
domain from toll and il-1 receptor and
the active domain would be from Sita
Lockton and and that was my strategy to
try to identify it and and that what I
took advantage of is that after many
many failed attempts to do it through
various types of approaches for
degenerate screening or by hybridization
or through PCR took advantage of the
fact that at the time new types of
genomic sequences started to be become
available this so-called expressed
sequence tags that were just short
sequences that were generated randomly
in multiple tissues and using by
informatica proaches and using conserved
consensus sequences for this cytoplasmic
domain for taller my own one receptor as
well as for sita lectins i started
searching these databases and found
several clones that correspondent either
to see Tatlock teens or to this
cytoplasmic domain and then i pursued
both of them and the one that
correspondent to see tapleft in domain I
found that it was most similar to those
awful at all and this was in some
starting in january/february in 1996 and
the the gel shown on the left here it
was I think one of the first clones that
I got which was later would turn out to
be a human homolog of tall and the gel
on the right and in this bottom band I
still remember that band because this
was one of the those happy moments in
the lab when I got this portion of the
receptor which was particularly
difficult to clone and then by doing
standard library screening through
hybridization we pulled out a full
length
of the cone encoding toll receptor
followed by five frame race technique
which was at the time popular in gene
cloning and eventually got the receptor
and by about May of 96 and then another
event that happened that in in the
summer of 96 we had a meeting in Charlie
summer house in Squam near Boston were
several other investigators participated
that shared human Frontier grant
including Allen's oculus Fortis kavadis
Joe's Hoffman and Charlie and and Jules
Hoffman and presented work of Bruno la
Mettrie from his lap about genetic work
on resultó past where were they found it
was involved in immunity so that was it
was further confirmation for our
expectation that this receptor might be
involved in immunity and so then I
characterized this receptor in terms of
its ability to control NF Kappa B
signaling shown here on the right and
more importantly for us at the time for
its ability to induce inflammatory
cytokines and the most important for us
the holy grail for us whether this
receptor can induce the second signal
costing two molecule shandong as b7 and
that was the the probably one of those
lucky moments in the lab when I saw that
total receptor which I rendered
constitutive because the ligand was not
yet known at the time
and transfected in this monocytes cell
line and when I saw that it can induce
expression of this gene that was the
moment when we thought okay this this
whole hypothesis now we can connect from
beginning to the end and I even called
char this was late in the evening I mean
called Charlie and told him that that
human toll can induce B so an expression
that was we would probably well be the
only two people in the world who would
be excited about that but nevertheless
others also
appreciated it and so we published this
paper in 97 where which is extremely
simple paper showing just cloning and
showing this a couple of functional
assays and and then subsequently in the
same year Ben Lewin who was the editor
of a cell at the time asked Charlie to
write a linear review about innate
immunity and so in in that mini review
we discussed questions about evolution
of innate and adaptive immunity and put
this schematic together to to show the
parallels and differences between
Rosella tall and mammalian tall pathways
where we suggested that recognition of
pathogen associate molecular patterns
things like LPS and dichroic acids and
so on is detected by tolls either
directly or through some intermediary
as is the case in drosophila and at
least two induction of NF kappa-b
and various innate immune response genes
and genes controlling adaptive immunity
and subsequent work indeed demonstrated
that they told that I worked on is part
of a bigger family there are about a
dozen of different toll receptors in
mammalian species and it's now known as
tlr4 toll-like receptor foreign cell
receptor for LPS and the receptor part
that detects LPS actually protein called
mg 2 that complexes Vistal and
subsequent work with my many
investigators elucidated specificities
of different toll receptors and Shizu
akira from osaka university in
particular played a major role in this
set of investigations and what we know
now is that if we our main interest was
not so much in microbial specificity of
receptors but in this idea that
microbial receptors can control
activation of adaptive immunity and this
is what schematically illustrated here
so we have
a dendritic cell which is a cell type
that normally activates T cells and when
dendritic cell encounters pathogen
what's shown on the left side here there
is a end acidic receptor that will take
our pathogen take it into lysosomes and
then proteins will be caught into
peptides and load it into MHC molecules
and present it to T cell receptors but
that information by itself is not
sufficient for T cells to know whether
they should become activated or not
because this peptide can come from
pathogen or it can come from innocuous
food antigens or it could be even self
antigen so T cells have known a no way
of knowing what's the origin of the
antigen s and the reason for that is
because T cell receptors are generated
at random and each T cell has one single
specificity but they are random so it
doesn't know what it's specific for so
therefore there is a need for another
signal so called signal tool which will
provide information about the origin of
the antigen that T cell is specific for
and that is provided by this detection
of microbial structures by toll
receptors and now we know several other
families of pattern recognition
receptors that detect those structures
and induce expression of questioning two
molecules and now T cell that has
specificity for peptide derived from
pathogen will also set have a
confirmation signal from costume to
molecule cdat cat6 also known as b7 one
b7 two and then T cell will become
activated and in addition toll receptors
and other pattern recognition receptors
will induce production of cytokines such
as al 12 that will tell T cells what
kind of effect your response to generate
and that is now of course well accepted
view how immune response is activated
and and it's it's a very satisfying to
see this confirmation of the proposal by
other Janeway which was at the time
largely ignored
and that now it become it's a it's a
textbook knowledge in the the immune
system that that's how activation of the
adaptive immune system is controlled and
all receptor was one of the first
receptors to demonstrate it to to be
involved in this process so that's the
story of this discovery and thank you
for listening
you